after weeks of wildfires only now are
they really starting to try and halt
their march through the Amazon the state
of Rondonia is one of the worst-hit
areas
it's where the Brazilian military have
started their work in places there's
hardly anything left the only sign of
life here is left navigating a scorched
earth it's claimed animals vegetation
and human life my neighbor has hundred
heads of cattle and there is no grass
left the whole family nearly died trying
to put out the fire nobody has turned up
over here only the environmental agents
who finds us the president of Brazil has
been accused of introducing policies
that have encouraged legal burning to
create farmland after international
condemnation they've now acted as
Brazil's Environment Minister explained
the plan he continued to deflect the
blame
we are making all efforts to take the
necessary measures to combat the illicit
environmental crimes in the Amazon
region additionally due to the
seriousness of the issues that we have
been following we are collaborating with
the agencies and state bodies who are
primarily responsible for fighting fires
in each of the respective states while
the rainforest performs the vital
function of absorbing carbon and
producing oxygen farming this land makes
money environmentalists adamant this is
a man-made crisis and it's spreading
here in Sao Paulo
1,700 miles away they've had almost
blackouts this week where the smoke has
drifted in and obstructed the Sun this
is a polluted city but people here just
haven't seen that before the rainwater
collection in this house to the east of
the city looked like this scientists
from two universities have established
that it did come from forest fires olavo
and his mother Maria can't quite believe
that it's reached their backyard and we
need a school we've known for a long
time about the pollution of the city of
Sao Paulo and we thought that was it
from the city now we see that it comes
from very far places from the Amazon the
arguments over who started the fires do
nothing to put them out the military
teams are now on this for the next month
and international help is on its way to
they are fighting thousands of fires in
one of the most remote corners of this
continent Tom Parmenter Sky News Brazil